Brechende Neuigkeit, die Dinosaurier lauschten vor ihrem Untergang dem Podcast UFO.
Völlig korrekt, herzlich willkommen zu seiner neuen Ausgabe von das Podcast UFO. schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid, mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan hier, auch immer Tiese. Dicker Lippen, dicker Lippen, dicker Lippen. Sehr gut, der neue Themesong für Dinosaurier im Allgemeinen. Ich habe erst was anderes verstanden, bin ich ganz ehrlich, und dachte mir, oh, hier gibt es noch neue Erkenntnisse für den T-Rex. Du hast ein bisschen schmutziger gedacht. Körbchengröße, T-Rex hatte grosse Brüste, habe ich erst verstanden. Kann ja sein, weiß man ja nicht, sieht man ja an den Knochen nicht notwendigerweise, kann ja die neue Enthüllung sein. Wir sind mittlerweile für alles bereit. Ja, offen und für alles bereit. Und inzwischen kippt es bei mir auch, weil es ist ja jetzt eh schon in so eine Lächerlichkeit gekippt, dass ich fast begrüsse, wenn es jetzt weiter in diese Richtung geht. Weißt du? Ja. Das ist fast so wie ein Autounfall, wenn man da noch nicht weggucken will. Ja. Ich bin so sensationalistisch, da muss mehr passieren. Wir sind auch abgestumpft gegenüber Enttäuschungen, wir wurden so oft enttäuscht in unserem Leben, deswegen kann uns das kaum noch treffen. Ganz im Gegenteil, allerdings hat uns Leon zwei nicht enttäuscht. Vielen Dank an Leon zwei, den zweiten Platz konntest du dir sichern. Aber wir haben ihn enttäuscht, weil er nicht der erste Leon ist. Ja gut, aber das ist ja mittlerweile auch schwer. Also mittlerweile gibt es ja kaum noch, viel Niklas natürlich wie immer, aber Leon ist auch gut mit dabei. Aber wir haben noch ein paar Namen offen. Also, falls ihr Josefine, Karl, Klaus, Franz, Wilhelmine oder Bernhard heisst, dann schreibt uns gerne euer Intro, denn wir haben euch noch nie gehört. Ich gebe dir für jeden, also ich habe jetzt die Liste herausgesucht, der beliebtesten Jungen und Mädchennamen 2022. Die aktuelle konnte ich gerade nicht so schnell finden. Und ich würde dir, ich gebe dir für jeden, was möchtest du haben?
100 Euro.
Okay, ich sage mal, wenn du einen Platz, aber da muss die Platzierung auch richtig sein, du machst es nicht selber auf.
Nee, nee.
Guck mir in die Augen.
Ja.
Okay, wenn der Platz stimmt, wenn der Platz stimmt, und ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich mache jetzt ein, wenn du jetzt George auf Platz vier votest, aber der ist eigentlich auf Platz drei, kriegst du keine hundert Euro. Du kriegst nur hundert Euro, wenn die genaue Platzierung stimmt, okay? Guck nicht auf dein Bildschirm. Frau Schöneberger, als ich zu diesem Promi-Quiz angefragt wurde, dachte ich, es ging eher so um Natursachen. Wie? Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, was das Quiz ist. Das Quiz ist, wir gleichen die Liste der beliebtesten Vornamen ab mit den Einsendernamen vom Podcast-UFO-Podcast-Entre. Nein, nein, nein, deine. Du musst jetzt raten. Du musst raten, ich gebe dir 100 Euro, wenn du die Top 5 errätst, der beliebtesten jungen Mädchennamen. Weltweit oder Deutschland? Deutschland. Platz fünf. Ottmar. Platz fünf wäre Sebastian gewesen. Okay, Platz vier. Platz vier, Bibo. Knapp, Nelio. Oh, Nelio? Noch nie in meinem Leben habe ich Nelio gehört. Ah, der lag auf der Zunge, war der Zweite. Nelio, Platz drei, ist das der Richtige?
Platz drei ist Fritz.
Levi.
Das sind alles Jungnamen, oder wie?
Das sind jetzt Jungnamen erst mal.
Dann Platz zwei.
Tassilo.
Liam.
Und Platz eins.
Mike.
Elias. Ach so, die Mädchennamen, fünf
Ähm
Sauna
Sophie,
na dran, Platz vier
äh, Platz vier
Lawine, oh, Lina
und Lina ist streng genommen die Mischung
aus Sophie und Sauna
also deine
eine kriege ich.
Platz drei.
Jacke.
Emma.
Platz zwei.
Sierra.
Emilia.
Und Platz eins.
Mike.
Nada.
Nada? Fucking Nala. Ach, Nala. Ich dachte Nada. Nein. Nada. Nada?
Fucking Nala.
Ach, Nala. Ich dachte Nada.
Nein. Nada. Fucking Nala.
Nala? Nala. Wow.
Wie von Simba. Die von Simba, die Olle.
Ach so, okay.
Nicht mal Grogu irgendwo dabei.
Wir sind völlig in den falschen Bubbles unterwegs.
Unterrepräsentiert Grogu und
der Mandalorianer.
Beide nicht vollkommen bei den Jungnamen. Schade, schade, bis vielleicht nächstes Mal. Ja, du hast null Euro verdient. Aber hätte ich die gekriegt oder wären die irgendwo gespendet worden? Die wären gespendet worden. Das ist ja eben meine beste Vorstellung bei diesem Promi-Quiz, wo die dann immer Geld sammeln und da heißt es, okay, Herr Frau Schoeneberger, Sie haben 160.000 Euro gesammelt als Spende für das Kinderhospiz. Was? Als Spende für das Kinderhospiz bei Werder. Was? Nein, ich habe das doch gerade erspielt. Frau Schöneberger, das ist doch für die Kinder, wir sammeln doch Geld für die Kinder. Aber ich habe doch richtig geraten. Ja, das haben Sie, wunderbar, nochmal Riesenapplaus für Frau Schöneberger. Ich wusste, dass Königin Elisabeth II. die Antwort gerade ist, nicht fucking Timmy mit einer Herzrhythmusstörung. Sie können sich bitte kurz hinsetzen für die Kamera, weil da werden sich die Kinder im Kinderhospiz bestimmt sehr darüber freuen, Frau Schöneberger. Was machen die mit 160.000 Euro? Ne, frage ich sie jetzt mal. Also, das können wir uns angucken, da sollen neue Betten gekauft werden. Neue Betten. Und neue Isolierung fürs Haus. Die schlafen bald sehr lange, verstehe ich jetzt nicht, warum... Frau Schöneberger, ich glaube, vielleicht können Sie sich ein bisschen mitfreuen für die Kinder im Kinderhospiz. Oh Gott, ja. Goldmäntel, kauft den Mäntel aus Echtgold. Ja, das war das Kinder ... Schnuller aus Blattgold, ja. Komm, roll credits. Ja, das war das Kinder-Promi-Quiz. Das war super. Vielen Dank an Frau Schöneberger, die den ersten Platz bekommen hat. Wow. Vielen Dank auch nochmal. Sie auch, Herr Jauch. Jesus Christ. Das war gerade Satire. Auf was auch immer. Es ist ja jetzt erstmal egal. Und das ist auch nicht unsere Aufgabe, das jetzt zu interpretieren, aber die Witze, die wir gemacht haben, waren hart, zu hart. Genau, also es richtet sich jetzt gar nicht gegen Frau Schünneberger. Oder gegen Kinder. Nein, aber auch nicht gegen Wohltätigkeit im Allgemeinen.
Oder Geld auch im Allgemeinen.
Nein. Genau, also es richtet sich jetzt gar nicht gegen Frau Schünneberger. Oder gegen Kinder. Nein, aber auch nicht gegen Wohltätigkeit im Allgemeinen.
Oder Geld auch im Allgemeinen. Wir wollen niemandem ans Bein pinkeln mit dieser ... Wir sind dafür da, dass Leute eine gute Zeit haben. Wenn es zu krass war, dann schreibt bitte eine SMS an podcast.org. Ufo. Oder auch wenn der, ich finde auch gut, wenn der Pomi so gar nicht laut wird, aber man merkt ihm an, dass ihm das nicht gesagt wurde.
Und er mit so Blicken so, habe ich das gerade richtig gehört?
Ja.
Und dann tippt er so Ralf Schmitz an.
Hey, hey, pst, hat die gerade gesagt, hat die gerade gesagt, Ralf, Ralf, was denn, Ralf, ist ohne Grenzen, habe ich verstanden. Hä, aber ich dachte, wir spielen für uns. Nein, wir spielen nicht für uns. Ich brauche Geld, ich brauche dringend Geld. Wir kriegen eine saftige Gage, wir kriegen eine saftige Gage. Was heißt saftige Gage?
Habe ich auch nicht nachgefragt. Im Vertrag steht saftige Gage. Was heißt das, wie viel ist das? Ja, also ich finde, 10.000 fände ich eine trockene Gage. Weil im Backstage gab es Saft, nicht dass das einfach damit gemeint ist. Ah, das ist nicht. Saft, also im Sinne von Saft. Entschuldigung, ich melde mich mal für alle gerade. Amazing, aber wenn Gruppendynamiken so funktionieren, dass sie eine Spokesperson finden. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir haben uns hier alle gerade gefragt, ob wir gleich gemeinsam Mittagessen machen oder ob wir jetzt schon mal überlegen, wo wir gleich was essen. Ja. Finde ich gut, wenn alle gemeinsam sich überlegen. Ganz kurz, im Namen aller Passagiere des ICE 128 nach Riga. Wir würden gerne wissen, warum wir jetzt schon seit 40 Minuten in Düsseldorf stehen. Genau, hier nochmal im Namen aller Zugbegleiter und Zugbegleiterinnen. Wir möchten nicht, dass Sie uns jetzt irgendwie jetzt hier ansprechen mittendrin. Wir arbeiten gerade an Hochdruck weiter, dass wir jetzt endlich mal hier aus Düsseldorf losfahren können. Wir sehen auch, dass es eine Verspätung herrscht. Aber im Namen aller Zugbegleiter und Zugbegleiter und der Schaffner und Schaffnerinnen würden wir gerne sagen, bitte halt doch einfach eure Fresse, okay? Alles klar, das gebe ich so weiter. Danke.
Und dann wird noch zehn Stunden diskutiert gemeinsam.
Erinnert mich an die Szene aus Herr der Ringe, das Enting, die Ents.
Ja.
Wo die Ents sich sehr lange versuchen zu einigen.
Eine clevere, auch hier, eine clevere Satire.
Man weiss nicht genau, auf Bürokratie, weiss ich nicht.
Ja, oder auf Pazifismus vielleicht, nicht zu viel reden, sondern Handeln.
Ah, smart, smart, smart, smart.
Was ist die Aussage am Ende des Tages? Was ist die Aussage? Das ist immer so die Frage.
Sie ziehen in den Krieg, aber sie wissen, es ist ihr Ende.
Ist es ihr Ende?
Ja, haben Sie doch gesagt, es ist das Ende der Ends.
Aber warum ist es ihr Ende? Die machen euch kaputt.
Habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Aber man sieht sie danach auch nicht nochmal.
Bei dem grossen Krieg am Ende machen sie nicht mit.
Wie das Ende? Das Ende, weil die dann kommen, glaube ich, die aus dem Wald rausufen, oder was? Wegen des Wortspiels wollt ihr jetzt nicht mehr weitermachen, oder was? Das ist Ente. Ente gut, alles gut. Ente gut, alles gut. Jesus, Baumbart, ey. Dad Joke, Baumbart. Der heißt Fangorn, ne? Hm? Der heißt Fangorn, der Wald. Nee, der Baumbart. Wie, er heißt Baumbart Fangorn? Das Baumbad. Der heisst Fangorn, ne? Hm? Der heisst Fangorn. Der Wald? Nee, der Baumbart.
Wie, er heisst Baumbart Fangorn?
Ja, Baumbart ist so der Name, den andere ihm geben.
Baumbart Elias Fangorn?
Sein Geburtsname ist Fangorn.
Wie? Ja.
Er heisst, wie der Wald heisst.
Genau, denn Wald, also, ne, immer unklar bei The World Building, wer wurde nach wem benannt, aber Baumgart ist nur was, was die zu ihm sagen. Er ist aber Fangorn. Elias Fangorn. Und ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, er stellt sich auch vor mit Baumgart, also das ist vielleicht so eine Fanta-Situation, wo er seinen eigenen Namen vielleicht so ein bisschen uncool findet und dann Leuten immer sagt, ihr könnt mich Baumgart nennen gerne. Aber wenn er so heisst, wie der Wald heisst, das wäre so, als würde ich sagen, hi, ich bin Köln. Oh, hi. Hi, mein Name ist Köln. Wo wohnst du? In Köln, hier in Köln. Ach so, okay. Die Stadt ist nach mir benannt. Die Stadt ist nach dir, ist das nicht verwirrend? Aber das ist doch, also, ne, sorry, sich Baumbart zu nennen. Ich bin nur der Sprecher der Tolkien-Gesellschaft.
Ich kann nicht für ihn sprechen, aber ich kann im Namen aller Tolkien-Fans sagen, dass das ja auch wieder nur, das ist ja nicht der Westron-Name, also das ist ja wieder nur der englische Name für Fangorn.
Das ist ja nicht so, wie die sich in der Welt nennen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur dein Sternzeichen wissen. Krebs. Danke. Ist das so schwer? Musst du am ersten Date immer mit diesem ... Herr der Ringe-Trivi anfangen? Naja, und jetzt gibt's ja das Herr der Ringe-Magic-Set. Au! Und das ist ja, also Crossover. Da kommen für dich ja zwei Welten zusammen. Und das macht viel Spaß, weil, also mal kurz ausholen, okay? Ja, ich halte die Luft an. Wenn man in Magic eine Kreatur ausspielt, dann darf man mit der Kreatur nicht direkt angreifen. Das geht nicht, das wäre zu stark. Manche Kreaturen aber, die haben die Sonderfähigkeit Haste, Eile, die sind besonders schnell, die können im gleichen Zug, in dem man sie ausspielt, auch angreifen. Jetzt gibt es viele von diesen sogenannten Keywords auf Magic-Karten, Fliegend, Trampelschaden, Hexproof, solche Sachen. Du hast mich verloren, weil das mit Hast und so war cool. Haste ist ein Keyword. Das Keyword steht auf der Karte drauf, es wird aber nicht erklärt. Es wird erwartet, dass der Spieler weiss, was Haste bedeutet. Manchmal, weil es viele von diesen Keywords gibt, werden die aber nochmal erklärt auf der Karte. In einem Reminder-Text, da steht dann Haste und dahinter in Klammern, diese Kreatur kann angreifen, sobald sie ausgespielt wurde. Damit man als Neueinsteiger nicht den Überblick über diese ganzen Keywords verliert. Und das sind random selektierte Karten? Das sind manchmal einfach, genau, wo einfach Platz ist, wo der Regeltext vielleicht nicht so groß ist oder wenn es ein Keyword ist, das lange nicht in Verwendung war, kommt das jetzt nochmal vor und dann macht man nochmal den Remindertext. Haste allerdings wird nie erklärt, weil Haste ist eine so basic Fähigkeit, die muss man nie erklären, da steht einfach nur Haste. Jetzt allerdings gibt es die Karte Schattenfell, Shadowfax, das schnelle Pferd aus Herr der Ringe. Von Gandalf. Von Gandalf, das natürlich schnell ist. Und das hat die Fähigkeit, alle Pferde, die du kontrollierst, haben haste. In Klammern, wenn diese Kreaturen aufs Spielfeld kommen, dann dürfen sie angreifen. Es gibt einen Remindertext für haste, haste wird also erklärt. Und was macht Shadowfax? Was sagt Gandalf? Shadowfax, show us the meaning of haste. What? Das ist ja amazing. Als Gandalf aus Helmstlam losreitet, um Eomer zu holen, sagt er, Shadowfax, show us the meaning of haste. Das ist ja nicht. Und Magic hat eine Karte gemacht, auf der uns die Shadowfax-Karte als einzige erklärt, was Haste bedeutet. Was für ein befriedigendes Ende für die langweiligste Exposition, die ich jemals in meinem Leben ertragen musste. Aber wie cool ist das? Das ist ja so wert. Gott sei Dank bin ich drangeblieben bei diesen zehn Minuten Horror. Anders als alle anderen, die geskippt haben. Aber es ist so cool, weil es nutzt bestehende Elemente von Magic, Remindertext, Haste, gibt es alles schon, aber es benutzt es so, um diesen Gag zu machen. Das ist ja fantastisch. Show us the meaning of Haste. Und dann schreiben sie es drauf, obwohl es nie erklärt wurde. Das war wichtig, dass du es vorher gesagt hast. Weil sonst habe ich gedacht, warum erklärst du mir, dass das konkret nicht erklärt wird. Erklärst mir noch an Beispielen, wo es erklärt wird. Aber dann ist mir nachher aufgefallen, das ist ja der wichtige Aspekt für dieses Befriedigen, der Ende der Geschichte. Fantastisch. Hast du ganz toll auch erzählt. Absolut großartig. Ich bin auch begeistert. Das ist genau das, was ich mag, wenn Magic-Karten so eine gewisse Idee so in Magic-Sprache umsetzen. Das macht mich glücklich. Hast du die Karte gesehen, bist selbst draufgekommen? Oder war das dann so ein Ding, was bei Reddit rumgegeben? Das war so ein Ding, das bei Reddit rumgegeben. Da muss ich ehrlich sein, das habe ich nicht selber verstanden. Aber cool, wahnsinnig cool. Da hat jemand alles richtig gemacht. Ja, total. Und Herr der Ringe hat quasi die Rechte verkauft an dieses Random-Ass-Kartenspiel. Ja. Hat verscherbelt, die Rechte verscherbelt. Ja. Weil bei Lego waren sie ja lange nicht dabei auch zum Beispiel, weil da wollten die ihre Rechte nicht für abgeben. Ich glaube, es geht auch nur ums Buch. Also nur die Buch-Rechte. Tolkiens Buch. Nicht das Filmen aus dem Film, nicht Jackson, sondern Buch. Und ja, cool. Ich freu mich. Nee, voll geil, find ich gut. Hast du schon gespielt damit? Nee, das kommt jetzt erst bald raus. Und ja, ist natürlich die Frage, viele Fans diskutieren, kann man das machen? Weil irgendwann gibt's halt dann das, hat man dann ein Magic-Spiel, wo irgendwie Frodo kämpft gegen Snoopy, während die Transformer, mein Transformer-Deck gegen dein Garfield-Deck mit Scooby-Doo als stärkste Karte. Das Problem ist ja auch in gewisser Weise, dass du in jedem Franchise findest du ja dein, gibt's ja ein Goat. Zum Beispiel im Garfield. Im Scooby-Doo-Universum ist es Scooby-Doo. Genau, im Garfield-Franchise ist Garfield der stärkste Protagonist. Der müsste die höchste Stärke haben, ja. Müsste die höchste Stärke haben. Das macht Sinn in einem rein Garfield-artigen Magic Deck. Wenn du jetzt aber, der gibt allen Katzen nämlich Haste. Obwohl Garfield ist ja träge, der isst ja immer die Lasagne, da würde Haste überhaupt nicht passen. Genau, show us the meaning of laziness steht dann auf der Karte. Nee, das macht keinen Sinn, egal. Verteidiger vielleicht, die können nicht angreifen. Genau, Probleme, aber jetzt natürlich, wenn man das mit dem Herr der Ringe-Set kreuzt, wo dann die Nazgul verliert gegen Garfield, weil es halt nicht die MVPs ihres jeweiligen Sets sind.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, weil Nazgul ja eigentlich schwächer sein müssten als Garfield.
Aber die sind auch riesige Drachen, fliegen die und verlieren dann gegen Garfield. Das ist natürlich jetzt albern.
Ja, normalerweise darf ein Deck immer nur viermal die gleiche Karte beinhalten.
Mhm.
Außer die Nazgul-Karte, die darf man zwölfmal haben.
Das ist ja ... Er hat langsam verliert ...
Die biegen, verbiegen sich aber ...
Ist schon ganz cool, oder nicht?
Ist cool, ja, ja.
Oder sind zwölf, ne?
Neun, dachte ich aber.
Du hast völlig recht, oder? Neun?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Heißt es nicht neun? Ich weiß es nicht.
Shit, Alter, wie peinlich.
Okay, dann nehmen wir das nochmal auf.
Das ist jetzt zu viel Credibility-Verlust hier für mich gerade.
Vor allem, du freust dich so sehr über deine erste Geschichte,
dass die rückblickend jetzt doof wird,
weil du dich offensichtlich nicht so sehr für Herr der Ring interessiert.
Das heißt, war das gerade alles nur gespielt?
Scheiße. Wenn du es jetzt nochmal ansetzt, das so zu erzählen, dann, das möchte ich nicht. Nein, der muss jetzt durch. Die Scham muss sich dann auch mit mir tragen. Ich habe vor ein paar Folgen behauptet, und selbstbewusst, und viel zu lange auch noch, ich habe die richtige Antwort dann gelesen, und war immer noch Mann, ich hätte recht, dass 60 mal 60 360 ergeben.
Wirklich? Das habe ich ja gar nicht mitbekommen. Da gab es ja gar nicht 90 Reddit-Posts, die ... Ihr seid solche pedantische Arschlöcher.
60 mal 60 ist 63. Das muss ich nochmal korrigieren, weil eigentlich gar nicht richtig, sei ich 3000.
Genau, da musste ich auch ...
Mein Gott, Leute!
Da musste ich auch durch.
Jesus.
Und jetzt musst du da durch.
Als ob das jetzt relevant wäre. Als ob das relevant wäre. Leute, Leute, Leute. Möchtest du dich dafür entschuldigen? Ja, sorry. Entschuldige dich bei der 60. Das ist eine der wichtigsten Zahlen, eine unserer treuesten Verbündeten, die immer nur Gutes für uns getan hat, und du hast sie in den Schmutz gezogen. Was hat die 60 jemals Gutes für uns getan? Die 60? Hä, 60-40? Das ist eine super Verteilung. 60-40? 60-40 ist eine geile Verteilung. 60 Prozent Arbeiten, 40 Prozent Freizeit. 60-40 ist die beste Verteilung. Was ist noch ein Beispiel für 60-40? 60 Prozent Wachsein, 40 Prozent Schlafen. 60 Prozent Dr sein, 40 Prozent draußen. 60 Prozent Hauptgang, 40 Prozent Beilage. Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, langsam, langsam. Jetzt wird es schon ein bisschen ... 60 Prozent Mittagessen, 40 Prozent Abendessen. Och, da gehe ich gar nicht mit. Die letzten paar Zahlen haben mich jetzt komplett off guard getroffen. Ja? Einfach so, die haben mich jetzt ein bisschen rausgebracht. 60 Prozent Grün, 40 Prozent Bebauung in Städten. Oh, das ist aber utopisch, oder? Das ist eine schöne Stadt. Du heisst Köln, aber hast du noch Einfluss auf die Kölner Stadtentwicklung als der ursprüngliche Namensgeber?
Köln wurde mir benannt. Aber kannst du deinem Stadtrat das nochmal irgendwie in die Waagschale werfen? Hast du irgendwas, was du in die Waagschale werfen kannst? Ich habe nichts in die Waagschale, ich kann mich in die Waagschale werfen, in der Hoffnung, dass es dann kurz so initial so ein bisschen runtergeht. Aber stimmt, ja, nur durch den Impuls. Da, wo ich Kaffee kaufe, die haben noch so alte Wagen, wo man als Kunde, also die haben, das ist richtig cool, Wagen, oder? Mit zwei A. Genau, ja. Und sie, dann wollte ich 500 Gramm von meinem gemahlenen Kaffee haben, und dann kriegt man, dann sieht man halt, es sind doch diese alten, mit so einem kleinen, so einem Pfeil, und dann sieht man, wirklich bewegt sich das. Und dann war bei 500 Gramm, und normalerweise machen wir ein bisschen mehr rein, aber der war jetzt sehr genau letztes Mal. Und genau bei 500 Gramm hat er dann aufgehört. Es gibt kein Gegengewicht. Es gibt kein Gegengewicht, es ist nur halt so eine mechanische Waage, die mir als Kunden halt auch noch zeigt, wo der Pfeil ist. Und dann hat er das dann fertig gemacht, gepackt, zugemacht, nimmt es von der Waage und ich sehe, dass sie nicht genau auf null zurückgeht, sondern auf eher so eins, ein Gramm. Da habe ich gedacht, boah, Leute, nicht mit mir. Oh Gott. Nicht mit mir, da habe ich gesagt, das geht ja jetzt nicht. Nee, ich habe es nicht angesprochen. Ich würde mich lieber umbringen, als das anzusprechen. Du meinst, man hat dich um einen Gramm betrogen? Ja. Um fünf Prozent quasi dann von fünfhundert. Das möchte ich mich nicht festlegen. Das hat der Nurches davon, dass man, wenn ihr so pedantisch immer schreibt und kommentiert, dann, man nimmt sich ein bisschen zurück.
Ja, das stimmt. Man geht ein bisschen in sein Schneckenhaus zurück und dann sagt, oh nein, das hat wehgetan.
Ich möchte nicht festlegen, wie viel Prozent das sind. Ein Gramm von 500.
Aber ich denke mir, ich stelle mir das unfassbar fucking nervig vor, wenn du im Mittelalter bist und du hast nur diese Zweischalenwaage und musst immer, und dann vor allem das Problem ist, wenn du sagst 500 Gramm, Herr Tietze kommt irgendwie, Kurfürst Tietze kommt zu meinem Export Handelswarenladen Händler, Krämer, Will und dann sagst du 500 Gramm gerne, Herr Tietze, kein Problem, das können wir gerne in die Wege leiten für sie, 500 Gramm auf der einen Seite und dann brauche ich ein Gegengewicht, das genau 500 Gramm wiegt. Woher weiss ich, dass das 500 Gramm wiegt? Weil dafür brauche ich ja auch wieder ein anderes Gegengewicht, um das sozusagen einzustellen. Ich muss einmal mir hundertprozentig sicher sein, dass dieser Stein genau 500 Gramm wiegt und wenn ich da den Überblick verliere, dann habe ich verloren, weil wenn ich nicht mehr weiss, ah, es ist 250 oder 500. Ah, shit, jetzt muss ich mit anderen Dingen das wieder so ... Ich glaube, es gibt es ... Glaubst du, man konnte besser schätzen früher? Gut, konnte man besser schätzen? Gibt es da Quellen? Alle tot leider. Aber ich glaube ... Lass uns mal gucken, ob es noch Leute aus dem Mittelalter gibt. Okay, aber ich glaube, man konnte besser schätzen, weil es eine viel wichtigere Fähigkeit war. Ja gut, aber das ist ja keine Grundlage. Dann sagst du, ja, das sind doch nicht 500. Ja doch. Ja, ihr wird es aber anders geschätzt. So, ich glaube, es gab mindestens im Mittelalter ein Handelshaus, das sich so hart in der Ecke manövriert hat, mit, nein, nein, aber wir wissen ja, das sind 400. Dann gibt es 400 und dann liegt noch zwei von, die Muscheln sind immer ungefähr 50, dann lebt noch zwei Muscheln und man hat sich am Ende so verheddert, dass alles irgendwie außer Balance war und die Leute nur Bullshit verkauft bekommen haben. Was mein Vater immer gesagt hat zu einer, oft zu den Uhren meiner Mutter, weil die weird geformt waren und man die Uhrzeit nicht ablesen konnte, hat mein Vater mal zu der Uhr gesagt, was sind Schätzeisen? Und das war, ist, glaube ich, ein Begriff. Das wird eher so weggelächelt, ohne dass jemand hinterfragt hat. Schätzeisen. In meiner Familie kursiert der Begriff Schätzeisen. Und ich glaube, das kommt daher, dass es halt früher ein Schätzeisen gab, was natürlich eine wahnsinnig ungenaue Art war, aber du hast immer so ein Schätzeisen mitgebracht, um quasi den Bäcker auf die Prüfung zu stellen. Ihr musst den Schätzeisen mit sich holen. Herr Müller will. Kann ich bei Ihnen ein 500 Gramm Mehl kaufen? Nein, die Pest. Ach, okay. Ich komme nächste Woche einfach nochmal wieder. Okay. Aber er kam nie wieder. Wegen der Pest. Nee, aber jetzt kann ich mal 500 Gramm Mehl haben. Ja. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Und dann habe ich mein Schätzeisen in der Tasche, was 500 Gramm wiegt. Du streckst den ganzen Tag 500 Gramm mit dir rum. Ehrlich gesagt. Es gibt keine Hosentasche, ne? Aber Leute tragen Mittelalter Rüstungen mit sich rum. Zwei Tonnen wiegen die. Ja, woher weiss man das? Weil ich ein Zwei-Tonnen-Gewicht dabei habe. Aber ja, ich meine, das ist, er öffnet natürlich Tür und Tor und Haus und Hof. Haus und Hose. Nee, er öffnet Haus und Hose. Nicht Hose. Jedweden Betrüger, der sagt, pass auf, hey, ich verkaufe dir gefälschte Schätzeisen, da steht 50 Gramm drauf, aber es sind eigentlich, jetzt lass mich kurz nachdenken.
Ich weiß genau das Problem, was du gerade in deinem Kopf hast.
Es sind eigentlich mehr.
45, weniger.
Nee, es sind mehr.
Weniger.
Nee, es sind mehr, damit du sagen kannst, ich hätte gerne 50 Gramm und als Gegengewicht ist es dann mehr. Vers, weniger. Nee, es sind mehr. Damit du sagen kannst, ich hätte gern 50 und als Gegengewicht ist es dann mehr. Verschiedene. Ich gebe, da steht überall 50 drauf. Und manche wiegen 40, manche 60. Je nachdem, wer verkauft oder kauft, schon klar. Nämlich, sag ganz schnell, wenn man verkauft... Kaufen höher, verkaufen niedriger. So, okay, ich leg mich fest. Wir brauchen auch Reddit-Kommentare, das ist auch nicht schlecht. Wir sind nicht so blöd. Ihr denkt, wir sind blöd, aber guck mal, wie schnell Führer und den gerade geantwortet hat. Wir sind nicht bescheuert. Aber das ist doch wahrscheinlich ein Markt, ne? Und dann muss der Betrüger... Ein Markt. Ach so. Und dann muss der Betrüger sagen, hey, ich würde gerne ein Schätzeisen machen, das 40 Gramm wiegt. Dann muss er das ja auch wiegen, aber vielleicht wird er auch wieder betrogen für dieses Wiegen des betrügerischen 40 Gramm, dass er eigentlich 50 Gramm sein soll. Und dann muss er das wiegen und wird auch mit einem falschen. Und der Fälscher hat ja Materialkosten. Das heißt, der Fälscher, dieser Schätzeisen, will ja eigentlich weniger Gewicht rausgeben, weil er, das heißt, selbst die 40 ist wahrscheinlich eher 39, weil er Materialkosten hat. Eisen kostet Geld, Schätzeisen. Ja. Das heißt, am Ende kursieren ganz viele verschiedene Schätzeisen, auf denen stehen alle 50 Gramm, und die einen sind riesig und sehr schwer, die anderen sind sehr leicht. Ja, vor allem, du kommst ja aus dieser Führung nicht mehr raus. Also wahrscheinlich gab es dann irgendwo so in Venedig so das Ur-Kilogramm und irgendwann einigt sich so eine Stadt, Leute, mal ganz kurz, wir haben komplette Scheiße gebaut, wir haben uns komplett in eine Sackgasse manövriert, wir gehen jetzt alle nach Venedig und passen unsere Gewichte alle wieder an das Ur-Kilo in Venedig an und dann machen wir weiter, aber bitte dann kein Betrug mehr, weil das macht alles kaputt. So eine Art TÜV oder so eine Dekra oder so eine neutrale Organisation, die dann zertifiziert, das ist ein geprüftes, in Venedig geprüftes, und das ist dieses CE-Zeichen, dieses Certified Europe. Das wird doch auch gefälscht. Und deswegen kommt man dann irgendwann an den Punkt, dass man sich einfach nur noch vertraut. Ja, okay. Du wärst untergegangen. Leider. Sofort. Komplett. Wenn du schon bei einem Gramm sagst, wenn du schon um zehn Prozent betrogen wirst bei deinem Kaffee, wenn du da nicht einhakst, dann hast du im Mittelalter aber ganz kleine Schuhe. Zehn Prozent von fünftausend sind. Ganz kleine Schuhe. Du sagst, ich habe Schuhgrösse 42 und der gibt dir Kinderschuhe und du,
ich vertraue dir mal. Danke.
Du läufst mit winzigen Schuhen durch die Gegend, du hast Fussschmerzen, es tut weh.
Ganz kleinen Hut, ganz klein, so ein Crop-Top.
Ah, guck mal, da kommt Köln, haaa.
Hi, hi.
Dip, dip, dip, dip, dip.
Und ich bin super nett zu allen, aber alle sehen auch dieses Naivling. Ja, oder es wird die neue Mode, dass man einen ganz kleinen Hut hat. Weißt du, was mir aufgefallen ist? Lieber ihr Grüß. Gegenwarts-Check. Machen wir kurz einen Gegenwarts-Check. Okay, gut. Und zwar eine Mode, die ich im Verschwinden sehe. Ja, also Gegenwarts-Check, liebe Grüße an die sogenannte Gegenwart von Zeit Podcast. Die machen wir den Gegenwartscheck, was bewegt uns. Und da geht es ja auch um Moden, was sind Moden, die kommen. Aber ich finde auch immer interessant, Moden, die gehen. Und zwar eine Mode, die geht, ist es, seine Webcam abzukleben beim Laptop. Ah, interessant. Die geht. Das haben vor ein paar Jahren alle gemacht. Selbst, und das ist ein sehr gruseliges Bild, selbst Mark Zuckerberg. Zag, Markerberg. Zag, Zag, Markerberg hat das gemacht. Und mittlerweile sieht man das seltener. Genau. Geht mal alle Laptops durch in eurem coolen, hippen Werbeunternehmen. Nicht mehr viele Laptopkameras sind abgeklebt. Jetzt musst du natürlich mit der Analyse präzise treffen, warum. Nee, ist es nicht, und daran scheitert ja auch der originale Gegenwartscheck manchmal die Aufgabe desjenigen, der das pitcht, jetzt die Lösung zu finden, weil die ist mir, die ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz klar. Ich würde behaupten, man gewöhnt sich an das Risiko, lebt mit dem Risiko. Ja, ich glaube, der Mensch gibt auf. Mensch gibt einfach auf. Oder dadurch, dass KI jetzt so als grosse Gefahr wahrgenommen wird, nimmt man andere technische Gefahren nicht mehr so stark wahr und sagt, naja, komm. Weil die Skepsis auch gerade gegenüber Apps und so ja eigentlich sowieso zunimmt, dass jetzt ja alle bei Signal, Mastodon, Snapchat und so sind, das heißt Threema, das heißt, man geht ja jetzt eher weg von WhatsApp und Insta und so was zu zu zum Beispiel, also Snapchat ist ja immer noch am Leben, eine App, die ja vor allem deswegen existiert.
Wenn man das sagen muss, ist es nicht. Das ist das Todesurteil. Wenn jemand betonen muss, dass du noch lebst, bist du eigentlich schon tot. Aber man geht ja zu Mastodon, weil, und da ist auch die Frage, wie viele machen das überhaupt,
prozentual so, weil man Twitter nicht mehr vertraut so richtig.
Oder man vertraut TikTok auch nicht.
Das heißt, es gibt ja immer noch so eine wahnsinnige Skepsis. Weil, und da ist auch die Frage, wie viele machen das überhaupt, prozentual so, weil man Twitter nicht mehr vertraut so richtig.
Das heißt, es gibt ja immer noch so eine wahnsinnige Skepsis
gegenüber, was machen die mit unseren Daten.
Deswegen verstehe ich es ja eigentlich nicht,
dass man aufhört, die Laptop-Kamera.
Aber ein Trend, und deswegen kriegst du den Punkt von mir.
Dankeschön.
Weil, der habe ich auch beobachtet, aber ich verstehe ihn nicht ganz.
Weil er ist nicht so ganz konsequent.
Die Frage ist, ziehen die Leute aktiv die Bedeckung wieder ab? Oh, man könnte sagen, wegen Corona mussten alle, haben alle gesumt, mussten alle das abziehen und haben es danach nicht mehr wieder draufgeklebt. Deswegen bekommst du den Punkt, Frau Power. Dankeschön. Das ist der beste Name der Welt, Nina Power. P-A-U-E-R, Power. Das ist der zweitbeste Name der Welt, direkt nach P-O-W-E-R.
Das stimmt.
Nee, finde ich so gut.
Ich habe nämlich jetzt einen Laptop, wollte ich verkaufen.
Das war auch merkwürdig ein großer Clusterfakt, der passiert ist.
Weil mein Laptop ist kaputt gegangen, mein Alter.
Schon vor ein paar Jahren, ich bin vor zwei Jahren kaputt gegangen, oder vor anderthalb.
Willst du uns einweilen, wie er kaputt gegangen ist? War es Wasserschaden, Fallschaden? Ja, wir haben ein Glas Bier drüber gekippt und dann war der kaputt. Dann war mir das so peinlich zu sagen, dann habe ich ihn abgegeben und gesagt, irgendwie funktioniert der nicht mehr. Noch tropfend, du mit einer Fahne einfach. Irgendwie funktioniert er. Ey, ich weiss nicht, was los ist. Ich wollte ein kleines Lässchen mit dem Trinken. Dann können sie hier nicht schlafen, das ist Graves, Sie können hier nicht. Und dann kam raus, Chip ist kaputt. Ich habe gesagt, ach, wie kann das denn passieren? Das war ein Lager, das hatte doch gar nicht so viele Umdrehungen. Gibt es ja nicht. Und dann hieß es, das wäre sehr teuer zu reparieren, er war schon ein bisschen älter, ich habe mich entschieden für ein neues Modell, habe den wieder mitgenommen. Und dann habe ich nämlich, oben hatte ich da so ein kleines Schiebeding. Das war ganz cool. Da habe ich so ein, das war irgendwann so ein Goodiebag drin. Das war oben so ein kleiner Aufkleber, den konnte man drauf machen und aufschieben. Das war richtig cool. Und den habe ich dann aber zum Verkauf abgemacht. Ich habe es dann ganz schick gemacht, den Laptop, hat es oben abgemacht und dann sah man das noch. Man sah noch sozusagen die Rückstände, wie so eine Ruine, wie Pompeji. Es war so konserviert. Wie der Hadrianswall, wo früher mal vielleicht ein grosser Wall war und jetzt nur noch so diese enttäuschende Winzige. Früher war der Fokus auf Datenschutz und dann sah man, ich habe es abgemacht. Man sah noch die Rückstände dieser alten, längst vergessenen Zeit. Genau wie, was auch aufhört, Sticker hinten auf die Apple-Logos zu machen. Hast du noch? Hab ich noch. Hast du noch? Aber das lässt auch manchmal noch nach. Und bei mir sah man auch noch den grossen Abdruck, weil Sonnenlicht und so war da ein wenig verblichen da drunter. Ach was. Sah man dann grossen Sticker da drum noch. Jedenfalls habe ich diesen Laptop damals dann nicht verkauft bekommen. Ich habe den für sehr wenig Geld bei Ebay, Kleinarzeigen reingestellt, den kaputten, habe gesagt, der ist kaputt, der Chip ist kaputt, habe die Rechnung oder die Analyse dabeigelegt, gesagt, wie viel das kosten würde, habe den deutlich reduziert und habe den reingestellt, habe den nicht verkauft bekommen, beziehungsweise wurden mir Preise angeboten, wo ich gedacht habe, ich habe eh so viel Angst, dass man dann noch einmal meine Festplatte wiederherstellen kann. Ich behalte den jetzt lieber. Ich hätte irgendwie 100 Euro dafür bekommen oder sowas. Hat den in mein Regal gestellt. Dann, letzte Woche hatte ich irgendwie so eine Aufräumwut und wollte Dinge verkaufen, die in meiner Wohnung rumliegen. Und dann fiel mir dieser Laptop auf. Dann habe ich mich geärgert, dass ich den nie verkauft habe und habe den reingestellt. Habe aber vergessen, dass er diesen Schaden hat. Oh nein! Habe geguckt, was der gerade so wert ist. Das ist so typisch aus Versehen Betrug, Stefan, einfach. Das ist so Dubai-Barbara Salitsch, so einfach, das habe ich vergessen. Ja, aber da war ein riesiger Bierfleck drauf, der hat noch nach Bier gerochen.
Mein Making the Murderer, wie ich so zu Unrecht im Gefängnis dann irgendwann lande, weil wegen Dummheit, wäre so being stupid, wäre so making stupid. Idiot, Idiot Part One. Dann habe ich vergessen, dass der, und dann haben mir Leute auch halt preisüblich, marktüblich gerade Preise angeboten für ein Laptop dieses Baujahrs. Und ich dachte, warum habe ich das nie verkauft, bin ich eigentlich bescheuert? Und ich habe mich verabredet, einer soll das abholen kommen. Und in so einer halben Stunde vorher fiel mir ein, ah, der geht ja überhaupt gar nicht. Der ist ja völlig im Arsch. Habe ich einfach vergessen. Im Laufe der Zeit ist diese Information in meinem Kopf abhandengekommen. Wahnsinn. Und jetzt habe ich den pausiert, abbestellt und jetzt überlege ich den wieder in mein Regal zu stellen. Und das Ganze wird sich jetzt so zyklisch alle vier Jahre wahrscheinlich wiederholen. Aber Wahnsinn. Ah, sehr schön. Aber ich fand gut, dass du abgesagt hast und das dir nicht zu peinlich war oder so du in so einer Sitcom-Strategie hättest sagen müssen, okay, ich muss den bei der Übergabe jetzt runterfallen lassen, damit er denkt, der wäre jetzt gerade erst kaputt gegangen, damit er nicht denkt, ich habe ein offensichtlich defektes Gerät bei Ebay reingestellt. Oh, oder man bringt den Abholer auf dem Rückweg zum Stolpern. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Du baust so ein Seil auf. Aber das darf erst sein, oder ich sag, kannst du kurz zur Hintertür reinkommen? Er kommt hinten raus und dann lasse ich ihn vorne wieder raus mit dem Laptop. Da ist dann aber ein Seil gespannt. Alle Nachbarn liegen schon unten an der Treppe. Die federn sogar vielleicht den Aufprall, was ganz gut wäre, weil wir wollen ja nicht den Käufer töten, sondern nur den Laptop zerstören. Und dann brauchst du noch so ein offenes Video von irgendwie Jura, Kaufvertrag, irgendwie Schaden nach Kaufvertrag, gibt es eine Frist. Was direkt angeht, auf so einer grossen Leinwand, viel zu laut, über allen Sonosboxen im Haus, läuft dann viel zu laut, warum es... Mein Name ist Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal und wir schauen uns heute an, wie ein Kaufvertrag funktioniert. Ah, okay. Interessant, wir gucken mal rein. Jetzt, wo es schon läuft, gucken wir einfach mal bis zu Ende. Ah, mein Arm! Können Sie kurz leise sein? Ah, fuck, ich glaube, der ist gebrochen. Hören Sie mal, der ist ein richtiger Anwalt. Das ist ein richtiger Anwalt. Alter, was war das denn? Wer spannt denn hier so ein dummes Seil drüber? Nur weil der bei YouTube läuft, ist es trotzdem ein richtiger Anwalt. Und ich stehe da unten, zeig wedelnd auf diese Leinwand, die da läuft. Und ja, dann kriege ich vielleicht meine 600 Euro. Und jetzt hast du das Sorgenkind immer noch zu Hause, oder was? Jetzt habe ich auf reserviert geklickt, damit alle denken, ah, da war wohl jemand schneller als ich. Und gäbe es auch einen Botten, ah nee, doch defekt oder so, Ware schlechter als gedacht oder gibt es nur reserviert? Ware im Schrank vergessen, doch schlechter als gedacht. Ich finde aber, du hast ein gutes Gedächtnis, nicht im Sinne von leistungsstark, sondern es ist ein optimistisches Gedächtnis. Negative Dinge werden einfach wegignoriert.
Das war kaputt, das brauchen wir nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir, geil,
ich habe nur einen Reiner, du musst es nur lange genug
nicht beachten und dann vergisst du die negativen
Aspekte. Ich bin sehr gut im Verdrängen
und das wird manchmal zum Verhängnis,
wenn man so Weihnachten alte Schulfreunde trifft
und mit so einem Optimismus
und so einer Lebens
ja frohe ausgestattet trifft man die dann und denkt, die Schulzeit war schon cool, war doch alles lustig. Man kriegt dann so Geschichten erzählt, wie man war oder was einem passiert ist oder was gemacht wurde. Und dann fällt mir wieder auf, mein Gehirn löscht einfach alle negativen Dinge. Ja. Aber ist doch gar nicht so schlecht. Du fährst halt immer wieder in denselben Urlaub, in dasselbe Hotel, das furchtbar ist, weil du immer wieder im Jahr dazwischen vergisst, wie furchtbar es war. Immer wieder vom gleichen Hausmeister in dieser Kammer eingesperrt. Immer wieder wird dir von der Cocktailsoße schlecht, jedes Jahr aufs Neue und nach dem dritten Shrimp fällt es dir ein, ach nein, das war ja die Cocktail-Sauce. Ich hasse alles an diesem Hotel. Ah, jetzt fällt es mir wieder ein. Ich mag Dänemark gar nicht. Ja, ist ein bisschen problematisch. Man entwickelt sich nicht weiter. Dänemark ist wirklich ein Toll. Pölzer, lecker Hot Dogs. Da sieht das als Beispiel genommen, weil Dänemark ist wirklich toll. Lecker Hot Dogs. Ja, aber Dänemark ist mehr als Hot Dogs. Das wäre das erste Satz zu sagen. Das ist dein Claim für Dänemark, das Land. Mehr als nur Hot Dogs. Mehr als nur Hot Dogs. Mehr als bloss Hot Dogs. Mehr als bloss Pölzer. Wir haben auch, nämlich Smörrebröd und Strände, Dünen. Ich mag Hot Dogs schon ein bisschen. Ich war lange auf ich war ja lange auf meiner kulinarischen Suche, ich hab dir erzählt, Wein, Drops of God, hab ich jetzt zu Ende geschaut. Sehr gut. Weine, und dann dachte ich mir, wie dumm ich bin, dass ich immer nur in Getränke denke. Ich sollte aufhören, in Getränken zu denken, sondern, weil man kann ja auch Sachen essen. Und deswegen bin ich jetzt unter die Pizzabäcker gegangen. Ich werde jetzt Pizzabäcker. Also hast du dir einen Pizzastein gekauft? Ich habe mir das klassische Ach, du willst gerade diese Woche mal Pizzabäcker werden, Starter-Set für 19,99 auf Amazon, Pizzastein und so ein Schieber und so ein großer Pizzakelle Pizzaschieber, es ist sogar ein Teleskop-Pizzaschieber, den man so aus und, also nicht aus und einfallen, sondern man kann den abschrauben und dann gibt es einen kurzen Griff und einen langen Griff. Und ich mag die Vorstellung, dass ich immer so wie in der Seite, so wie so eine Schwertscheide, habe ich die jeweils unbenutzte Variante, sodass ich im Workflow ändern kann, den langen abschrauben und den kurzen anschrauben, falls ich es brauche. Aber sehr cool, dass du in einer zwei Quadratmeter BG-Küche dann so einen Teleskop-Pizzaschieber hast, das war eine wichtige Entscheidung. Und ich, also, man hat ja manchmal so Tagträume, man überlegt sich so diese Klassiker, kennt wahrscheinlich jeder, Was mache ich, wenn ein Einbrecher reinkommt und dann verliert man sich in diesen Heldenfantasien, ich würde dann kämpfen oder whatever. Und dann überlegt man sich ja schon manchmal, geht man so seinen Raum, man geht seinen Raum durch. Du hättest keine Hass. Nein, man geht mal so den Raum durch, was könnte ich als Waffe benutzen? Und bisher muss ich zugeben, klar, mein Schwert,
aber in Hamburg zum Beispiel
habe ich nichts. Und dann dachte ich mir,
okay, jetzt habe ich diese
Pizzakelle zumindest.
Du bist ja manchmal
so kurz vorm Einschlafen in diesen
ja, was mache ich eigentlich, wenn es brennt?
Was mache ich, wenn irgendwie im
Zug irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der entgleist?
Was mache ich dann? Und dann denkt man sich ja, okay, was sind die Handgriffe, die ich sozusagen internalisiert haben muss? Und jetzt habe ich tatsächlich mir diesen Pizza, also nicht in der Küche gelagert, sondern neben meinem Bett, so dass wenn jetzt ein Becher kommt, diese riesige helle Bade, diese Pizza, helle Bade in der Hand haben.
Jetzt wird es fast mir zu gefährlich als Selbstverteidigungswaffe.
Weil jetzt hast du so eine ...
Du kannst ihn super krass verletzen, den Einbrecher.
Meinst du? Ich meine, du hast ja mal gesagt, du hast einen Baseballschläger.
Ja, habe ich vieles gesagt.
Damit man bei dem nicht einbricht.
Hast du ihn verkauft?
Ja, ich habe ihm viel zu viel Geld verkauft.
Ich habe vergessen, dass er schon gebraucht ist.
Ja, das ist einrichtet. Hast du ihn verkauft? Ja, ich habe ihm viel zu viel Geld verkauft. Ich habe vergessen, dass er schon gebraucht ist. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob man mit so einer ... Also ich glaube, so eine Kelle ist erstmal ein gewisser Abschreckeffekt. Weil es ist ja wie ein Schild an einem Speer. Es ist ja quasi eine offensive Defensivwaffe, weil du kannst ja mit dieser grossen Platte am Ende auch viel ... Ist sie nicht sauscharf? Die ist nicht sauscharf. Die ist doch sauscharf. Die ist schon, hat eine gewisse, ja, pikante Schärfe, ja. Aber sie ist jetzt nicht wie ein grosses Schwert oder so. Ist da noch so ein Rest Pizza dran? Na klar, natürlich, ein bisschen Mehl, damit es schön abgleitet vom Gegner. Oh, aber das finde ich nicht so schlecht, wenn du dann auch noch daneben legst so eine Mehl, so eine Mehl-Tüte, Mehlpackung und dann quasi so Bam Bam mässig so dem Mehl ins Gesicht machst. Pizzaman, ich habe alle Fähigkeiten von Pizzabäcker. Wie im Kampf Jack Sparrow gegen William Turner. Genau, die Asche. Die Asche. Nee, welchen Teil meinst du jetzt? Teil 1. Ist ja auch jetzt egal. Gehört der jetzt auch hier nicht hin. Gehört auch in diese Diskussion. Nee, war das nicht Mehl? Mehl meine ich nämlich auch. Nee, der hat doch eine Schmiede. Und da ist der Esel, der dreht. Was braucht man dafür? Irgendem Material zum... Warum, was dreht der Esel eigentlich in Teil 1 von dem Zug der Karibik? Das habe ich alles nicht verstanden. Diese ganze Architektur dieses Dingens ist eine Schmiede. So ein Blasebalg oder sowas? Nee, da hängen nämlich Schwerter dran auch. Da hängen ja, da zieht der der schmiedet die alle. Ich. Und ich übe mit ihnen. Also das, ne. Ja, ja. Aber, ähm. Genau. Aber ist das eine Mühle? Ist das eine Hybrid-Schmiedemühle? Oder braucht man mit dem Schmieden irgendeine ... Da gibt es doch auch so automatisierte Hemmer.
Nee, es ist tatsächlich eine Schmiede, eine Mühle und eine DHL-Packstation.
Weil der hat damals schon geschnallt, dass man mit einem ...
Weißt du, man verdient nicht Geld nur als Schmied.
Lotto-Totto-Turner.
Darum ist es auch Tabak und DHL-Packstation.
Lotto-Totto-Turn.
Ähm, das ist jetzt wichtig, dass du das genäzt. Mule. Mule-Scene.
Genau, der dreht aus dem großen ...
Also vier Zentiliter Tamarinden-Orangen-Rumlikör
und zwei Zentiliter Limettensaft hinzugeben.
Was?
Caribbean Mule.
Du bist abgerutscht.
Ich bin ein bisschen falsch abgerutscht.
Warum nicht Cocktails?
Warum machst du nicht Cocktails und gibst die dann mir zum Beispiel
zum Testen oder so was, wo ich auch was von habe. Deine Hobbys, da habe ich immer nicht so viel von. Aber nur kurz dazu, wie geil das wäre, wenn du halt immer quasi in deiner jeweiligen Phase die auch die Selbstverteidigung genutzt neben deinem Bett. Da hast du jetzt dann so eine Mehlpackung, schmeißt dem Angreifer Mehl und dann haust du dem wirklich so an die Kehle und schneidest dem dann so den Kopf ab mit der helle Bade. Ja, finde ich richtig gut. Nachdem du die Teleskop. Aber nur aus Interesse, hast du dich für die lange Version Selbstverteidigung entschieden oder für die kurze Version? Die lange. Weil du dann glaubst... Distanzklasse fern, du brauchst immer Sperre, sind immer gut. Zweihänder aber. Das sind Zweihänder, ja. Da kannst du die ganze Mehl-Sache vergessen. Die Frage ist, wie viel Zeit ich noch habe. Deswegen habe ich ja wie so Kletterer, die haben doch immer an der Seite so einen Magnesiumbeutel und da kann ich auch einen Mehlbeutel haben, den muss ich natürlich erst anschnallen, aber dann bin ich bereit, dann mache ich jeden fertig. Und ich stelle mir mal so vor, wie man dann so vor Gericht sitzt und der Richter so mit angestrengten Blick so, sie haben ihm erst Mehl in die Augen geworfen und ihm dann mit der Pizzakelle die Halsschlagader aufgerätzt. Und du hast dann so ein langes, so ein Schwanenhals-Mikrofon und dann drehst du dann immer so, immer bei jeder Antwort neu zu dir und machst dann so, ja. Und das war, sie haben jetzt Pläden auf Notwehr, sie hatten aber die Pizzakelle bereits am Bett. Blicke mit dem Anwalt werden ausgetauscht, wieder das Mikrofon zu sich. Ja. Und dafür war es zwingend notwendig, ihm Mehl in die Augen und die Tomatensauce in die Ohren zu sprühen und dann mit der Käsereibe quasi seine gesamte Stirn wegzureiben, um dann zu sagen, Mama Mia, um ihm dann mit der Pizzakelle den Hals aufzuschneiden, ihn ausbluten zu lassen und ihn dann im Ofen zu backen.
Ja.
Und das ist alles Notwehr.
Sehr suggestiv. Man darf es nicht übertreiben.
Einspruch, suggestiv Frage.
Kann man dem Richter stattgegeben?
Kann man dem Richter sagen?
Sorry, gut, dass Sie es sagen, da bin ich jetzt selber ein bisschen abgedriftet.
Und wissen Sie, und deswegen mag ich Sie so gerne als Richter, weil Sie dann auch Fehler sich eingestehen.
Wissen Sie was, Freispruch?
Wissen Sie was, ich lade Sie jetzt ein auf, eine schöne Pizza.
Ja, so, sehr schön.
Richter müssen auch essen.
Ist das der Romanentitel, an dem du gerade arbeitest?
Ja.
Justitia hat auch das Magenknurren Justitias. Nee, Justitia hat auch Kohldampf. Der neue Schlüsselroman von Stefan Költhize. Was mir in dem Roman gefällt, ist, dass er sozusagen ein bisschen das Rechtssystem aufs Korn nimmt. Ja, er nimmt eine Konstante, die wir als selbstverständlich wahrnehmen, das Rechtssystem und weist hier Irrungen, Wirrungen undes und ich glaube, das habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, es ist das Stilmittelmängel-Exemplar, also es wird sozusagen damit gespielt, dass hier Fehldruck, dass hier Kapitel falsch angeordnet sind. Er hat sich hier für diesen Paragrafenstil entschieden, was natürlich ein besonders starkes Augenlich wirft auf die Zusammenhängigkeit. Also er fängt an mit Paragraf 116b, dann kommt Paragraf 5. Das rüttelt auf. Das rüttelt auf, aber hilft uns das weiter? Meta ja, aber zu welchem Preis? Verständlichkeit, das ist klar. Nee, ich fand es Schrott, muss ich sagen. Scheiße. Schundliteratur, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Warum, man ist auch nie ausfällig geworden beim literarischen Quartett, oder? Man hat nie gesagt, scheiße. Ich find's scheiße, ich find's boring und lame und lame. Und dann setzt Marcel Reich an und man sagt lame. Lame.
Ne, gab es selten, glaube ich.
Ich bin jetzt noch nicht komplett durch, keine Spoiler bitte.
Ich bin nicht komplett durch. Ich habe nur gehört, dass am Ende einer davon den vier nicht mehr dabei ist, aber ich weiß nicht mehr wer. Ja, und deswegen, ich bin jetzt in der letzten Staffel Succession und versuche tatsächlich wie durch so eine Schlangengrube mich zu manövrieren durchs Internet, um nicht gespoilert zu werden.
Und ich habe es tatsächlich einmal nicht geschafft, weil ich habe einmal mir so ein YouTube-Video angeguckt und dann sieht man ja in den Related Videos manchmal Final Scene und dann leider im Titelstand schon, was die Final Scene ist. Aber ich schaffe es einigermaßen, das auszuklammern. Ich versuche wirklich, ein Gedächtvakuum das dann auszublenden, klappt nicht immer. Ich muss aber auch ganz ehrlich sagen, dass mir das bei der Serie auch nicht so wichtig war. Weil ich finde, es lebt nicht, und klar, die Serien finden alles immer was anderes, aber es lebt, das finde ich für mich nicht, über die konkreten Twists und Turns und Story-Entwicklungen, sondern bei mir war es bei der Serie eher, ich will Zeit mit diesen Leuten verbringen. Ich will Zeit mit diesen Charakteren verbringen. Ich finde die alle spannend und ich vermisse die jetzt. Das ist das Post-Serien-Trauma, was ich jetzt gerade habe, diese Post-Shirt-Depression, weil man seine Freunde vermisst. Was, mit Fanfiction? Man wird die nie wiedersehen. Interessiert dich dann Fanfiction gar nicht?
Ja, wie Roman Candle zwei Stunden lang mit einem Metalldildo in den Arsch weckt.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das das konkrete...
Wir haben ein...
Möchtest du Fanfiction? Das ist doch Fanfiction.
Wir haben ein böses Wort pro Folge.
Wenn du noch eins sagst, dann müssen wir leider den Explizit-Button drücken.
Was war es jetzt?
Na, du hast das F-Wort gedroppt. Die F-Bomb hast du gedroppt. Das geht, einmal darf man. Einmal ist familienfreundlich. Einmal das kann man überhören, beim zweiten Mal muss ich dann Massnahmen erzielen. Das ist nämlich mein Beispiel jetzt für den Gegenwarts-Check. Spoiler verlieren an Bedeutung. Dadurch, dass jetzt jeder so ein eigenes Tempo hat, Serien auch so breit gefächert sind, jeder guckt andere Serien, man spricht nicht mehr darüber, man kann nicht mehr darüber reden, wie bei das Wetter, weil es eben nicht jeden beeinflusst. Jeder ist irgendwo anders, alles ist zerstreuter, weniger zentralistisch auf eine Serie ausgelegt. Ich glaube, der Spoiler verliert langsam an Bedeutung. Mhm. Trotzdem bitte nicht spoilern, wenn's geht. Nee. Ich bin noch nicht da. Bei Succession war ich jetzt froh, dass ich ... Ich hab alles am Stück durchgeguckt und war dann genau zur letzten Folge fertig, konnte dann die letzte Folge mit allen anderen gucken. Das heißt, ich hatte sowohl dieses Lagerfeuer, die Staffel ... Die Serie ist jetzt vorbei, das Staffelfinale der letzten Folge Folge, gucke ich mit allen anderen, aber ich hatte trotzdem nicht dieses ewig lang eine Woche Warten gedöhnt. Dann war ja auch bei der ersten Staffel irgendwie noch Covid oder sowas, wo dann auch nochmal zwei Jahre gewartet wurde auf die nächste Staffel. Diesen Scheiß hatte ich alles nicht, ich habe es einfach am Stück geguckt. Nachteil, man kann mit niemandem drüber reden, so richtig, jetzt dann wieder, weil es dann wieder so aufkam, der Hype.
Aber es ist natürlich schon cool, wenn man jede Woche mit jemandem darüber reden kann.
Deswegen finde ich auch die Selbstauskunft wichtig.
Einfach, wenn du mit jemandem in Gespräch gehst, sag, pass auf, ich bin noch nicht in der letzten Staffel, damit der andere nicht sagt, boah, aber die letzte Szene mit dem Uwe.
So, sondern einfach, dass man auch weiß, okay, pass auf, hier sind meine Grenzen, sprich darüber hinaus.
Verkaufen, verkaufen, hier sind meine Grenzen, sprich darüber hinaus. Was mir denn nicht gefällt, man kriegt dann immer mit, ah es ist super, ah es ist, wird dir gefallen, ah nee, das hat gar nicht funktioniert und so, das will ich ja auch schon nicht wissen. Nee.
Ich nehme meinen Gegenwartspunkt zurück, kein gutes Beispiel, ich glaube Spoiler verlieren nicht an Bedeutung.
Ich hätte aber auch gerne umschrauben müssen. Nee. Ich nehme meinen Gegenwartspunkt zurück. Kein gutes Beispiel. Ich glaube, Spoiler verlieren nicht an Bedeutung.
Ich hätte aber auch gerne Hubschrauber, muss ich sagen. Das ist schon immer geil. Das ist cool. Das ist schon immer geil. Das finde ich auch gut. Diese Vorstellung, da steht überall einfach einer bereit für dich. Allein diese Privatjets, die sind ja sehr reich in der Serie, immer diese Privatjets zu haben, so ein Flugzeug für sich alleine. Aber da habe ich jetzt gehört, es stürzen ja prozentual viel mehr Privatjet-Piloten ab als Linienflieger. Lufthansa kaum Unfälle, Privatjets die ganze Zeit. Ja, 50 Prozent. Weil das sind nicht die guten Piloten. Die Leute, Privatschitz fliegen, sind nicht die guten Piloten. Und jetzt, ich als Superreicher, denke mir, weiß ich nicht, ob ich jetzt gerne einen Privatschitz hätte. Und Helikopter ist, glaube ich, ich habe gerade mit jemandem gesprochen, der wohl irgendwie in eine Familie eingeheizert hat, wo ganz viele Lufthansa-Menschen drin sind. Und er hat gesagt, aus der Familie steigt niemand,
nicht mal so Sightseeing-mäßig in den Helikopter,
würde niemand einsteigen.
Weil Leute, die Piloten sind und Flugzeuge fliegen,
hassen Hubschrauber.
Das verstehe ich jetzt.
Wieso das denn? Ist das so ein Grabenkampf?
Es wird unsicher geschimpft.
Ist das so ein PlayStation-Xbox-Ding oder was?
Ich glaub ja, Android-Apple. Das ist so ein Tom-and-Jerry-Ding. Wer jagt hier wen? Wir sind eine Flugzeugfamilie. Du steigst jetzt hier nicht in Hubschrauber. Ich durfte meine ganze Jugend nie in Hubschrauber steigen. Von den Machern von Billy Elliot. Kommt jetzt und dann... Aber Mama, ich will Hubschrauber fliegen. Ich möchte Leuten in gefährlichen Bergsituationen helfen und dafür sind Flugzeuge einfach nicht gemacht. Dann bist du nicht mehr mein Sohn, Billy. Die unglaubliche Geschichte von einem Jungen, der gegen alle Widrigkeiten Hubschrauberpilot werden wollte. Verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen, verkaufen. What? Ja, aber das, ja, ich glaube, das gibt schon so einen großen Kampf. Aber auch aus Unsicherheit, aber gut, auch vielleicht behauptet. Aber ich glaube, es stützen trotzdem prozentual auch mehr Hubschrauber ab. Okay, gut, wunderbar. Sorry. Ja, wir hoffen, dass ihr gerade nicht im Hubschrauber sitzt. Sie sagt so, oh, es ist ein sieben Stunden Hrauberflug, oh, was lade ich mir runter? Natürlich, klar, sicher, Podcast-Ufo, letzte Folge. Stimmt das, dass in Fliegern keine Filme gezeigt werden, in denen ein Flugzeug zu Schaden kommt? Ich glaube, das stimmt, ja. Was ist mit Planes, so wo die sprechen können, die Flugzeuge, ist das dann auch ein bisschen verwirrend? Was ist mit Tenet? Ja, eben. Das Flugzeug steht ja am Boden und fährt in Gebäude. Es fliegt nicht in Gebäude, es fährt. Wo ist die Grenze? Haben die Leute denn Angst auf der Startbahn? Oder denken die sich, naja, fliegen wäre das nie passiert. Ich glaube, bei Tenet ist sowieso sehr viel egal. Bei Tenet ist es so, was macht jetzt diese 747 da? Die fährt rückwärts aus einem Gebäude raus, das sich wieder zusammensetzt. Ja, aber in der Vergangenheit. Herr Nolan, sorry, wir müssen dieses Gespräch führen, ich bin derjenige, der entscheidet, wer die Flugzeugfilme freigeht. Lassen Sie es einfach laufen. Aber erklären Sie mir nochmal, das Flugzeug ist in der Vergangenheit, fährt rückwärts in die Gegenwart. Also es wird so ein Zangenangriff durchgeführt. Das heißt, man kommt, das blaue Team, okay, hören Sie, das blaue Team ist schon zurückgereist, weiss schon, lebt von den Erfahrungen, die das rote Team hatte. Aber das Zukunftsteam weiss ja schon, dass die Missionen erfolgreich sein. Richtig, genau. Sein wird in der Vergangenheit. Genau. Whatever happens, happens. Happened, happened. Also die können gar nicht mehr selber eingreifen. Jetzt wird es auch ein grammatikalisches Problem. Okay, also mir geht es nur darum, sehen wir ein Flugzeug, dass es zerstört wird. Aber auf dem Boden, auf dem Boden. Und es ist, okay. Rückwärts, aber in der Vergangenheit. Also es baut sich quasi zusammen. Es geht nicht kaputt, sondern es wird sozusagen im Laufe des Films wieder aufgebaut. Man könnte sogar behaupten, dieser Film muss im Flieger gezeigt werden, weil es gibt keinen anderen Film, in dem ein Flieger repariert wird. Herr Nolan, ich respektiere Ihre Filmkunst, aber das überlassen Sie mal bitte dem Experten. Und ich respektiere Ihren Job sehr. Dankeschön, das freut mich. Das höre ich selten, muss ich sagen. Einen fantastischen Job interessiert sehr, aber es ist der erste Film, wo ein Flugzeug zusammengesetzt wird. In Aviator gibt es ein paar Szenen, wo man sieht, wie das Flugzeug gebaut wird. In Aviator.
Aviator mit ...
Aviator.
Den Cabrio, das müsst ihr doch kennen.
Ja, ist doch wunderbar.
Das respektieren wir, glaube ich, beide.
Ja, ich möchte nur sagen, dieser Film muss in gewisser Weise laufen.
Mehr möchte ich gar nicht sagen.
Denkanstoss.
Gut, das ist angekommen, die Entscheidung liegt am Ende auf meinem Schreibtisch.
Aber gut, dass wir das noch mal erklären könnten.
Ein Flugzeug wird rückwärts zerstört, also repariert quasi. Ja, gut. Und Inception? Ja, Inception, da langt sie. Den habe ich selber nicht verstanden. Da weiß ich auch nicht. Der Kreisel am Ende kippt vielleicht um. Wir sehen, davor gehen wir raus. Ja, wir haben versucht, dass er kippt, aber irgendwie ... Das war so ein magischer Kreisel, der irgendwie immer ... Lustigerweise sind Filmfehler. Erst im Schnitt dachten wir, das ist das Ende. Das war eigentlich nur so nebenbei, und jetzt ist das Ende. Aber in manchen so superreichen Autos gibt's doch auch hinten Bildschirme. Dürfen da dann auch keine Filme gezeigt werden, wo Autos zu Schaden kommen? Baby Driver. Du meinst, okay, das alte Baby Driver-Problem. Cars, Baby Driver, Drive, Speed. Ich glaube, es ist kaum möglich, einen Film zu zeigen, in dem kein Auto kaputt geht, dass es einfach kaputt war. Also findet Nemo, Shrek und das war's. Kannst du dann gucken. Schreck gibt diese Kutschenverfolgungsjagd. Es darf nicht auf Kutschen, in Wien nicht auf Kutschen gezeigt werden. Shrek ist leider raus von der Wiener Regierung. Ist leider raus. Und nach der Logik hätte Inglourious Bastards auch nie im Kino laufen dürfen. Richtig. Reiner Home Release war jetzt leider nicht, ist zu gefährlich. Rainer Home Release, das ist mein Name.
Wirklich? Sie sind ja Home Release?
Ich mein Name ist Rainer Home Release.
Ach was, das ist ja interessant.
Ja.
Und wenn man Filme zu Hause schaut, das wird nach Ihnen benannt, oder wie?
Ja, kann man so sagen, genau.
Ach was.
Das hier mein Bruder Freiburg.
Okay, wow, hi.
Hi.
Oh, fuck.
Hui.
Uh, das ist ein Charisma, das geht durch den Raum. Das weht durch den ... Oh, Freiburg.
Mein Name ist Freiburg. Hallo Freiburg.
Die Stadt wurde nach mir benannt.
Okay, in welchem Jahr?
1994.
Oh, und wie hieß die Stadt davor?
Darmstadt.
Kann ich noch ein Stück Pizza haben? Ja, na klar.
Und dann stehe ich ganz weit weg,
aber ich habe so einen Teleskopaufsatz
und reiche ich dir die Pizza.
Das ist meine Pizzeria.
Und schiebe ich dir die in den Mund, mit so einem kleinen,
ganz kleinen Teleskop, dass ich dir in den Mund schieben kann. So Toffee-Fee-Groß. Aber das ist meine Vorstellung von der Pizzeria, dass es keine Kellner gibt, sondern wenn du die Bestellung aufgeben musst, dann musst du so auf so eine Bing-Glocke hauen und dann kommt mein ganz langer Teleskop-Schaufelstab raus, da müsst ihr die Zettel drauflegen, was ihr essen wollt, und dann geht sie zurück in die Küche, und dann nach einer Zeit kommt auf dieser langen Teleskopkelle die falsche Pizza. Sie haben schon die richtigen Pizzen, aber ich lege die immer einfach random zu Leuten. Also man muss dann selber nochmal gucken, Moment, du hattest Spinacchi, warte, ich hatte Fungi. Wie in jeder Pizzerier. Ich weiß ja nicht, welche zu welchem gehört. Wie sollst du das wissen? Und da ich nicht so gut sehen kann aus der Küche, landet die Pizza auch teilweise neben dem Teller oder irgendwie auch. Aber ganz kurz mal eben, du hast ja gerade so in einem Nebensatz gesagt, dass du jetzt Pizza-Konnie servierst und machst jetzt Homemade-Pizza auf deinem eigenen Pizzasteinchen. Ja. Jetzt mal eine Frage, weil was ich immer doof finde an selbstgemachten Pizzen, ist eigentlich alles, also die selbstgemachte Pizza. Das ist auch meine Ersteinstiegshürde. Weil die sind meistens scheiße und es liegt meistens aber auch an dem Teig, dass der nicht so cool ist. Es gibt ja extra Pizzamehl, da kann ich den zum Beispiel in Köln, ganz bei mir in der Nähe, gibt es einen coolen. 14 Prozent Protein ist der perfekte Wert für Pizzamehl. Und da muss man z.B. auch mischen. Protein im Mehl? Ja. Und das ist perfekt. Und ja, das Ding ist immer so, wenn du so Rezepte anschaust, ja, Teig kneten, dann 20 Minuten Ruhe lassen, okay, ich schreib mit. Und dann nochmal kneten und dann nochmal 10 Minuten Ruhe lassen, okay, alles klar. Dann aufteilen in die Stücke, wie man es will, kann man wiegen. Und dann zwei Tage im Kühlschrank. Komm, ey. Kann man das nicht mal in den ersten Zeilen des Rezepts mal erwähnen, dass es irgendwie eine Wochenaktion ist? Ja, weil oben eine Dauer zwanzig Minuten steht. Netto, netto Dauer. Bullshit einfach. Arbeitszeit. Ja, Arbeitszeit zwanzig Minuten verteilt über eine komplette Woche einfach. Aber, sei mal, jetzt nehmen wir das Ganze mal als Always Look on the Bright Side of Life. In zwei Tagen hast du es ja dann quasi eingeholt. Und dann hast du ja noch, dann hast du jeden Tag fäustet dich über die Sachen, die du vor zwei Tagen in den Kühlschrank gestellt hast. Ja, ich weiß, aber es ist ... Und irgendwann kannst du auch von dem Hefeteig, der existiert, kannst du quasi die Hefebakterien nehmen. Stefan, du sprichst mit einem Menschen, der so ungeduldig ist, dass ich in meinen Jugendjahren mal Wackelpudding gemacht habe und ich so ungeduldig war, dass der endlich fest wird, dass ich ihn getrunken habe. Ja, ich verstehe. Also das ist die Person, mit der du gerade sprichst zum Thema Zwei Tage warten auf Pizza. Du sprichst mit einer Person, die das gemacht hat, aber wo das Gehirn das gestrichen hat, diese Erinnerung. Von daher, ich versteh dich, ich versteh dich. Ich hoffe, du wirst diese Folge nicht aus deinem Gedächtnis streichen, sondern dich für den Rest deines Lebens daran erinnern, irgendwann kommt dir nochmal die Erinnerung hoch. Und an euch natürlich auch die Bitte, bitte vergesst uns nicht. Bitte behaltet uns im Hinterkopf. Ja, was ist das negative? Weil sobald man vergessen wird, ist man ja quasi so gut wie erledigt. Okay, alles klar. Ich wünsche euch eine verstandesste Woche, weil es kommt gut durch die Woche, habt viel Spaß. Weil letzten Endes existieren wir nur in eurem Gedächtnis, in eurer Welt. Alles wird gut. Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns reinlasst in eure Welt. Alles wird gut. Alles wird gut. Okay.
Bis nächste Woche?
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
Okay.
Tschaui.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab.